welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is the breakdown of House
of the Dragon episode 9. this video is
brought to you by Pluto TV the free
streaming platform offering free movies
and shows that are 100 free 100 of the
Time episode 9 the green Council where
the Beast beneath the boards is revealed
and it's what Lara's strong wishes he
was when those boards are being walked
by Allison Barefoot I'm gonna break down
all the Game of Thrones nods and visual
details you might have missed first an
opening credits update the shot that
we've seen in past weeks of the two
bloodline branches representing viserys
and Damon now tilts back to show
viserys's dial for the first time in a
while showing it now flooded with blood
to mark his death then we follow his
bloodline to the green side joining
Allison's her dial we now see in close
up a seven-pointed star and that blood
spills downward to four dials with their
four children aegon which is a nude
woman with a crown because he's a
deviant Helena a spider because she's a
bug girl amend a sapphire because under
that eye patch is a huge sapphire in his
eye socket and further up on that wall
behind them is the fourth kid Darren who
has been left off screen is season but
confirmed by George R Martin to have
been sent to old town he's going to play
a bigger role next season but then a
bloodline from brother and sister aegon
and Helena flows down to their three
kids jayharis Jahira and mailor Jairus
and Jahira have a six-fingered emblem
because in Fire and Blood George R
Martin said jaharis boasted six fingers
on his left hand and six toes on each
foot this is what you get with incest
then an overhead passing shot shows
Damon's bloodline which branches one way
to where Bella and Reina are but now
Forks another way toward renira's dial
Damon's blood flows in an aqueduct
Bridge High over raniera's stream maybe
suggesting him being a generation older
than she is and then their combined
Branch flows into two dials for their
young sons aegon and viserys this
episode opens on the iron throne and all
of the red keep vacant and dead
viserys's life truly was the one
Keystone a piece keeping this whole
castle together and now he is gone
composer Ramin jawadi opens with piano
which is not common in Game of Thrones
as it's a more modern instrument and
jawadi first used it in Game of Thrones
for the light of the seven in the season
six finale which years ago I went deep
into in the breakdown script that I
wrote for the channel back in 2016 when
I had to give my co-workers a crash
course in music theory and back then
light of the seven played over a morning
montage and this montage is even earlier
in the morning in the pre-dawn hours
what though westerosi named hours would
probably call the hour of the
Nightingale which might be the birds
that we hear
child spies like this boy in Game of
Thrones when deployed by Varys were
called his little birds this is a
network of spies used by Otto since
episode 4. if this kid's soft viserys
die with his own eyes according to Talia
it means that this kid either camped out
in the king's chamber or to routinely
sneak in there to check to see if the
King was breathing this opening music is
called lament and note the notes that
jawada uses as the boy descends the
steps
[Music]
I love it not only does Melody follow
the downward action the last note there
is an example of dissonance when two
tones Clash to create a harsh unpleasant
sound in this case it sounds like
seconds on a scale in which the notes
are just too close together on a scale
to harmonize so with just this single
note jawadi communicates the structural
tension throughout this episode among
the characters because this episode
despite its focus on the green side of
the family it presents several couplets
who should harmonize normally but here
are squeezed too close together so that
they Clash we see this with sir Harold
and Sir Kristen the brothers Eric and
arik brothers aegon and aemond and
starting here in this scene with Allison
and Otto Allison sits behind her father
picking at her fingers her long time bad
habit returning with her anxiety Talia
lights the candles in the window which
is likely her way of signaling mazaria
from across the city that the king is
dead in a small council meeting master
of laws Jasper Wilde rolls the
attendance ball to Thailand Lannister
this ball is gold fitting for House
Lannister suggesting each of these balls
represent the house or person and also
signaling that Thailand Lannister is
about to take over as master of coin
Otto says we grieve for viserys the
peaceful viserys
is however notice how
notice how he repeats Allison's claim
that viserys in his final words wanted
aegon to be king yes there is much to be
done as we've previously discussed now
and just with displacement of the ball
their plans proceed Thailand says the
treasure
already gonna be divided for safekeeping
very big deal for master coin Lyman
beesberry he's supposed to be in charge
of the treasury but now this master of
ships just crept into his Department
Otto says that they need to send Ravens
to their allies at River Run and
highgarden River Run refers to Lord
Grover Tully mentioned in that land
dispute back in episode 6. he's the
supporter of the greens and remember
Grover has a grandson named Elmo and
great grandsons named Kermit and Oscar
those are their real names all these
conspirators are in on it even maester
Orwell in Lyman deesbury will not stand
for it he accuses them of treason and
even killing the Kings or Kristen steps
in I will have those spots
the ball smashes into lyman's eye socket
it really does seem like the show
invented these balls just to have
something to crush into beesbury's face
sir Harold westerling reprimancer
Kristen sir Kristen whose job security
is that it's inexplicable as his
agelessness Kristen lowers his sword
first but he only Shades it synchronize
perfectly with the movement of Sir
Harold But Otto forces them all to
finish the meeting with lightning just
bleeding out on the table his pool of
blood spreading out like the bleeding
dials in the opening credits Tylan says
Storm's end is of concern
we may not assume the Loyalty of Lord
Boris but he has four daughters all of
them unmarried the right proposal
storms and was shown in episode 4 where
we met Boris father boramanda Baratheon
who was strongly aligned with rhaenis in
the tourney in episode 1. this whole
Outreach to boros will end in an epic
conflict that we will likely see in the
finale Harold resigns in the kingsguard
but in the text his succession is caused
by his death not his resignation so like
Leonor valarian this leaves another
major player alive to play a role in the
war to come his resignation may recall
Barris and sell me dramatically giving
up his Lord Commander title in Game of
Thrones remember sir barriston went on
to serve a rival Queen Elena says it is
Our Fate I think to Crave always what is
given to another if one possesses the
thing the other will take it away she is
talking about her kids Jairus and Jahira
in kids natural Envy but also a deeper
comment on human nature and The Power
Within families like everything Helena
says we're gonna revisit this line later
trust me I like how on the table our
candle holders with seven pointed Stars
just further example of Allison's
redecorated based on the faith of the
seven Allison asks where is that gone
not here
he's not in his rooms yeah rooms aegon
has multiple rooms referring to a main
bed chamber but also other rooms where
he does his more messed up stuff Helena
goes silent just refocuses on her
embroidery which at first looks like a
spider remember her dial sigil in the
opening credits was a spider but this
thing only has six legs so maybe an
insect like a beetle or a snowfly or
maybe a spider but she just hasn't added
the final two legs yet on drift Mark she
talked about spools of green and black
and spiders in Weavers and embroiderers
are archetypal symbols of Fate the kids
are also playing with these toys that
look like they were woven by Helena it
looks like a fly or maybe a dragon or
maybe a dragonfly or a bee or maybe a
firefly I just think that there is an
insectoid connection between Helena and
lyrics remember who's Kane bore the
Sigil of a firefly that six-legged
spider could be a symbol for Laris a
cunning operator and a weaver in his own
right with like 75 walking capacity due
to his club foot Elena snaps again when
she muttered at dinner last episode
beneath the board this episode confirms
what she meant by that radius's Dragon
melee smashing up from the depths of the
Dragon pit but Helena says it here not
as a worried warning but it has a bitter
accusation toward her mother as if
Allison's decision to Crown aegon to
force radius's hand like that is really
to blame for all this Otto enlists Sir
Eric and Sir arik to find aegon in the
city Eric is aegon sworn protector but
he let aegon sneak out all the time
likely because he hates the pervy Prince
and doesn't care if something happens to
him the light of the seven parallels
heightened as jawadi's score shifts into
a new track called fate of the kingdoms
[Music]
foreign
now mixes in a fuller string section in
this Bell chime to underscore the
resolve that rhaenys feels after being
locked in her chamber locking her in
like that it will prove to be a fatal
error in the final sequence the realm
needs the doors opened for rainey's not
closed on her now in the text Renee said
already fled King's Landing on Dragon
back at this point remember we didn't
see her at the Last Supper but this
series keeps her around here to set up
this climactic exit and to give e best a
bigger Redemptive hero moment in many
ways she is the hero of this first
season but like all heroes of Game of
Thrones one who makes a huge freaking
mistake Pluto TV has on demand and
linear channels curated by real people
who select the movies and channels you
love some of your favorite binge-worthy
shows and movies have their own channels
that you can watch 24 7. comedy drama
sci-fi horror and for house the dragon
fans plenty of fantasy they've got it
all and it's all free head to pluto.tv
to check it all out Kristen and Eamon
look for aegon on behalf of Allison who
wants to control this succession in a
way that doesn't enter Rainier's
Bloodshed Eamon says aegon took him to
the street at silk on his 13th birthday
he's had time to get it wet every woman
is an image of the mother to be spoken
of with reverence now it's hard to know
how sincere Kristen is when it comes to
his reverence to the faith but when he
speaks to the mother he's at least
thinking of Allison who me also takes
personal fans on people and sold her
character and this informs his love for
her it's not the lust that he had for
when era but something closer to what a
son feels for his mother when we first
see
otta gathered Lord some are already
kneeling at the start of that scene
suggesting that Otto had to make little
argument for some to recommit their
fealty from rhaenyra to the greens but
one Lord refuses I am no oath breaker
I will not bend the knee this Lord
Meriwether a house from the reach their
Sigil of the Cornucopia on his chest
there lady Bell represents fellwood from
the stormlands Alan Coswell is the Lord
who greeted renyra last episode in the
yard lyrics notices that he's the last
one to bend the knee and since it's his
reluctance and disloyalty Eric and Eric
find a children's fighting ring the
kid's fingernails and teeth are ground
down when one kid swipes at another he
could see a trail of bloodmess left in
the air it's just awful but then again
this Civil War to come will be fought
most viciously among the children of
these family factions Eric nods to a
silver-haired kid sitting off on the
side I got one of many had wager this
kid is confirmed to be Gaiman pill here
a character from the text aegon's
bastard raised on the street of silk who
plays a small and pretty sad role in the
Royal conflicts to come so I really hope
this series gives him a more active role
with a name like game on because as of
now the implication is that aegon is
breeding kids in order to have a
gambling Advantage when they fight in
this Peewee Fight Club which is some
truly depraved [ __ ] until you realize
it's basically what we do with football
Allison watches as a silent sisters rap
viserys's corpse and she holds a
handkerchief to her nose because this
rotting corpse would likely stink for
the several hours that they kept him in
this chamber
in the text they keep his body in this
chamber for several days Allison asks
for rainey's support telling her that
the Iron Throne was hers by Blood and by
temperament we do not rule
but we may guide the men that do
gently
away from violence and short destruction
and instead toward peace this recalls
the great Council of 1-1 at the start of
this series when the Lords of Westeros
chose viserys over rhaenis again an
argument could be made that the real
focal character of this first season is
rhaenys because it all began with Throne
being denied from her Allison reveals
that they're keeping rainey's Dragon
melis there as a safeguard to keep her
Nera from attacking with her dragons
Allison says true Queen counts the cost
to her people he did you toils still in
service to men no father your husband
your son you desire not to be free but
to make a window in the wall of your
prison so here the two women outline
their values for Allison it's the cost
for rhinis it's the freedom and release
his complete lack of care for human cost
becomes clear in this final scene when
she wipes out hundreds of civilians in
her pursuit of Freedom Otto meets with
mazaria realizing that she is the White
Worm or are you simply a further feeling
this stinking onion yeah produce comes a
lot in this exchange the stinking onion
Missouri says when Otto plot ripens and
as of aegon I could have killed him as
easily as a wasp one fruit so we get
this visual of a rotting vegetable
replaced with a new fruit on the vine
and flying insects threatening it all
missouria is a mistress of Whispers In
conflict with the Whispers of Laris and
his fireflies Eric and Eric find aegon
hidden in an altar in this sept which is
not the sept of Baler because that's not
built until later in history this is a
different sept suggesting that even this
sept will be destroyed so that Baler can
build a new one later with Allison
positioning herself as a devout
worshiper of the seven the Civil War of
the series may have a religious War
component Eric fights Kristen But Eric
hangs back as aemond restrains aegon let
me go and we'll find a ship and sail
away never to be found he has similar
proposals sir Kristen made to Rainier in
episode 5 to give up Royal Duty and just
sail away to essos but now Kristen knows
that wasn't realistic for him so it's
not going to be realistic for the Future
King Otto seals emissive descend via
Raven sealing it with green wax this is
likely going to his allies back in Old
Town where his fourth grandchild did
Aaron is Allison ought to argue about
the game they're both playing how Otto
moved her around like a piece on a game
board but now that she has aegon she is
calling the shots and she chooses peace
with renira my husband would have
desired this message
my husband or you his daughter's
childhood companion this is especially
insulting to Allison but was Otto who
pushed her out of the role of renero's
best friend and into the role of the
King's new wife Otto even twists that
insult with his final words here you
look so much like your mother in certain
lights remember is Otto who made Allison
wear her dead mother's dresses to better
seduce viserys hilarious we learn has to
deal with Allison to satisfy his foot
fetish in exchange for Intel remember in
episode 6 Allison took off her shoes
when she sat down with lyrics and now we
know why this scene starts with a
close-up of hilarious Club but so it's
just kind of hard not to armchair
psychoanalyze his malady and his fetish
as being connected he refers to
mazaria's spy Network as spiders and
Weavers and this Weaver watches me yeah
and as we cut back to Laris he is the
one watching her here he's the Weaver
Missouri is the white worm and her kids
are the little birds really only Helena
has been likened with spiders and with
Weavers I think he's trying to deflect
attention from his own spy operation and
I think Elena might be connected to it
Lara says and queen dies
the bees fly without purpose yeah
another instance of Larissa's connection
with flying insects it's like he's the
fly proud of being able to evade the
spider's web Eric escorts rhaenys
through the courtyard past the hanging
Lord Coswell and threw the dungeons past
the skull of balerion Rainey stops to
take in this Beast beneath the boards
getting inspiration for the power move
that she will make at the end of the
episode Missouri is home Burns we don't
yet know if mazaria herself is dead in
the dragon pit a septon prepares to the
anointing ceremony a squirrel is
unfurled with his prayer script
including the refrain of seven above in
request to each member of the seven to
bless and protect them in various ways
the second paragraph references aegon's
conquest and how their enemy's blood
runs into the soil which is an
interesting contrast with the blood
rivers that flow in the opening titles
imagery they don't flow into the dirt
but on to these Stone Surfaces but the
blood of their enemies being in the soil
means that every tree flower and fruit
and Westeros is fed by the memory of
their enemies giving a deeper context to
the weirwood trees with their blood red
leaves watching these dragonlords in
judgment the third paragraph references
is a cataclysm visited on the sept this
is referring to the burning of the
septum remembrance during the faith
Uprising in which megor the cruel used
valerion to burn the sept and on its
ashes he built this Dragon pit where
they now stand so this pit is a big
grudging Hallowed Ground for the septins
and one could argue cursed to the
targaryens the crown laid out is not
viserys's Crown the one also worn by
jaharis but aegon the conqueror's iron
crown with its rubies the one last sworn
by maegor the cruel but Allison is
trying her best to legitimize aegon II's
Ascension with symbolism of the
Conqueror his crown historic blackfyre
and his dagger Allison gives aegon this
dagger in the carriage and simply
holding the Stagger seems to hypnotize
aegon with a sense of Destiny Allison
begs him not to put Rainier to the sword
but he seems not to hear her similar to
how Cersei and Sansa will beg the boy
King Joffrey to show Mercy to Edward
Stark and jop will ignore the whales of
women aegon takes the walk
foreign
uses the same King's March theme that he
used for viserys's Long Walk last
episode the septum who anoints aegon is
septon Eustis this is the septin
attached to the red keep from this point
forward during the Civil War and the one
whose historical account forms the basis
of the in the universe history of Fire
and Blood Kristen is the one who crowns
aegon crown of the Conqueror passed down
through generation and with this Crown
aegon does fulfill viserys's dream that
he told Emma back in episode one The
Dream
it was clearer than a memory our son was
born wearing a gun's iron crown and what
we'll follow in the words to come is
what he dreamed the sounds of thundering
Hooves and the splintering shields one
by one aegon's family members bow their
heads in respect but Eamonn only gives
the slightest nod King aegon II basks in
glory and Allison allows herself a
relieved smile but it really just seems
like that smile is the Fateful trigger
[Applause]
rainey's Dragon mellies explodes out of
the pit beneath and I love how when she
Roars you can hear a distinctive female
cry there
[Music]
rhaenys walks the dragon up to the Deus
and Allison steps forward putting aegon
behind her Eamon and Helena though
interestingly hold firm Eamonn has faced
down a dragon before the largest dragon
in the world vegar and Helena as a
dreamer is empowered in this moment she
now knows that she truly is a prophetic
dreamer and because she has visions of
the future she knows that she's not
gonna die here now again raineys and
mellies crashing aegon's coronation is
not in the text this was unique to the
series rainies could have ended the
conflict here just by torturing everyone
on the stage but chooses not to which I
guess is a good thing for us because
otherwise there would be no more show
after this but within the context of the
story rainey's just made a fateful
mistake that would cost countless more
lives in a civil war that she knows will
follow he best told vulture in an
interview that rainy says respect for
Allison as a woman in a mother and she
said it's an intelligent choice not to
torch a whole bunch of innocent people
in the room that it's not her battle the
writer of this episode was asked by The
Hollywood Reporter how rainy's justifies
that with killing a bunch of civilians
by even busting out and the writer said
it's Game of Thrones civilians don't
count but you know it's not also Game of
Thrones is House of the Dragon you can
make a difference is you don't have to
have dragon Riders wanted Lincoln
civilians without provocation but
whatever but this Beast beneath the
boards is just the start of the family's
Reckoning a false sense of Duty and
Destiny that curses every single one of
these targaryens arguably renice
wouldn't have had the idea to do this
has she not passed the skull of valerian
beneath the castle of the red keep and
hang on the second wouldn't be so
fortified in his resolve if this
coronation wasn't embarrassed like this
and had he never been Enchanted by
aegon's cursed dagger with every
generation that message just gets
further and further bastard eyes and
thanks again to Pluto TV for sponsoring
this video Pluto tv offers live channels
and on-demand blockbuster movies stream
now pay never you can follow me on Tick
Tock Instagram and Twitter at avos
subscribe to new rockstars thanks for
watching bye
foreign
[Music]